oui thierry j'ai encore beaucoup
travaillé là depuis samedi dernier j'ai
un peu compulser mes dossiers bonsoir
présidence je constaté qu'il ya encore
une dimension qui manque dans cette
émission se sont dédits mix avait ses
petites phrases qu'on répète à l'envi
jusqu'à ce que qu'elle rentre dans la
tête des gens ce que maintenant nous
avons la dimension petit jaune avant la
dimension reality show je rêve de
commence en être vraiment sûrs l'appel
une belle grosse émission de télévision
et nous n'avons pas de limite dans le
monde en six langues en dévoilant ses ça
ces petites phrases comme ça qu'on
reconnaît parce qu'ils n'auront pas
tellement il ya un truc qui marche pas
ce mot bien c'est nagui qui serait
vachement bien pour vous c'est
c'est toute l'allemagne est tout à fait
tirer en plus si vous appelez thierry la
mairie
j'attire votre attention mon cher
président sur le fait qu'il faut que
nous ayons nos propres gay mika ben oui
ce n'est même région les 2 c dans l'air
dimanche on a la paix alors j'ai bien
travaillé là dessus et je suis en mesure
de vous proposer trois gimme qui colle
parfaitement hardy matt je vous propose
la formule c'est royal top ça ça me
plaît ça hein ça veut rien dire c'est
fini je vous propose une expression
chère à notre ami président vous l'avez
employé plusieurs fois depuis que vous
êtes parmi nous c'est ça envoie le bois
ah oui un nouvel e 10 e voir ça dans ce
que c'est si j'ai un cousin qui est
forestier dans les cévennes
oui vous ne l'avez déjà dit valoir le
président et disons quelle que soit la
profession du cousin je rembourse envoie
le bois m il conviendrait de le dire
également et puis je vous fais repose à
bientôt tôt au lieu de à bientôt et des
communications présente de dire à
bientôt
à bientôt et à mon avis ce sont des
formules qui sont susceptibles d'être
reprises très vite par les écoliers les
t-shirts bien sûr là après les cartables
tout ce qui se vend tout ce qu'ils sont
alors j'attends simplement évidemment il
faut que tout au long de l'émission et
la champagne et non je vous demanderai
de vous associer à notre effort il faut
répéter ces trois formules aussi souvent
que moi ici alors naturel maroc
actuellement il faut que ça envoie le
voici journée qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la manoeuvre mon cher président ben
je crois que vous avez une idée royal
touch dit l'abe a bientôt tout elle
généré par exemple cet homme a décidé de
prendre tous les risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher le
zapper et conserver son hardy matt il
est prêt à tout tous les moyens sont
bons même la qualité
[Musique]
les
à
[Musique]
non
ouais c'est hardy matt l'émission qui
ont voile noir etc sophie marceau django
edwards
gustin hélène sans les garçons marie
pierre cazé vasile de codes du figaro le
professeur
ah le président lorrain le chien arte
royal tom et moi qui envoie le bois
bienvenue au studio bonaparte pour hardy
matt je tiens à vous faire part de
remarques eux qui m'ont été faites selon
lesquelles je manqué un petit peu
d'enthousiasmé une attitude un petit peu
crispé je serai pas très souriant
contrairement à nombre de mes collègues
sachez que j'en suis conscient et je
suis prêt à faire tous les efforts
nécessaires pour vous satisfaire
oui c'est bien de le dire
thierry joue très bien ouais quel effort
là des trucs par exemple ça à regarder
c'est drôle je sais que c'est une
chaussure de clown dans le désert
ah oui en effet ferwana top assez royal
table sans voix le bois il ya simplement
un petit détail qui vous a échappé le
probablement d'envoyer ce que vous avez
devant les pieds ouais ouais
ce qui fait que la chaussure ne se elle
se voit pas elle ne se croient pas alors
pour la drôlerie confié à thierry vous
repasserez j'y arriverai pas j'y arrive
je ne serai jamais de chavannes jackpot
génie on m'a dit j'ai un autre truc ça
se voit pour le coup comme le nez au
milieu de la figure là ça c'est marrant
et un ennemi mais il suffit pas de se
déguiser en clown encore faut-il faire
le clown oui oui oui j'ai vous raconter
une histoire alors bon moi je vois bien
ouais vous connaissez l'histoire de paf
le chien bo les airs non mais je sens
que je ne vais pas tarder à la connaître
c'est l'histoire de paf le chien ans
c'est un mec qui roule à toute berzingue
dans sa caisse
et puis dans un virage a le sien
par ailleurs je m'en fous j'en vois
derrière
tiens mon chantier rivaux l'émission qui
commence dans la joie la bonne humeur et
la franche poilades posément bien là les
jeunes comme il est désormais de
tradition je vous propose un petit bilan
de la semaine passée la séquence qui a
le mieux marché la semaine dernière
c'était la séquence consacrée au chapeau
jackson et saint cyrice était votre idée
est là vraiment vous applaudissez pas ça
méritait bien ces quelques
applaudissements extrêmement spontanée
et je vous disais réellement en neuf
semaines neuf idées géniales
honnêtement on peut dire que vous êtes
ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision
[Applaudissements]
été bien fait quelques applaudissements
très spontané et puis en même temps
cette semaine en 10e semaine 1
j'ai bien peur que tout magicien que
vous êtes vous ne parveniez +1 a trouvé
une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé ah
ouais l'écoutent alors tendez cela moi
veut ni un phil jackson extraordinaire
jackson comment vous est venue cette
idée géniale
thierry bas j'étais au restaurant avec
ma femme et d'un seul coup je me suis
dit le serveur s'appelait philippe vous
mangiez quoi sans indiscrétion j'ai
mangé des côtelettes défini vos
professeurs s'appelait philippe et
jackson philippe philippe jacq c'est ça
ça envoie le web on ice et royal top
ouais si phil jackson
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle fait jackson sa
mère
bonjour je m'appelle philippe lac sonne
c'est un nom à consonances britanniques
mais qui s'écrit à la française
j ai assez que deux assauts m voilà
d'ailleurs
je peux vous le prouver c'est un nom qui
est très ancien dans ma famille fait
remonte à plusieurs générations
je vais vous le prouver par les lecteurs
de ma carte d'identité d'ailleurs tout
de suite si vous voulez et bon jeu peut
la sortir la carte
alors voilà jacquesson j ai assez que
deux semaines philippe gérard pas
vraiment britannique 14 août 1962 paris
nationalité française patine particulier
un mètre 73 résine de gens voilà c'est
tout simple je vais d'ailleurs vous
pouvez par la carte d'identité et voilà
sans transition un vrai débat qui
mobilise la france toute entière
l'été les potiches vous avez
certainement remarqué que l'une d'entre
elles valérie la blonde manquent à
l'appel en effet vous avez été des
centaines de milliers nous demandé son
expulsion de l'antenne car la semaine
dernière à la question passer à la télé
c'est à changer quoi dans ta vie
sexuelle
elle a donné la maladroite la réponse
suivante revoyant l'action ralenti tout
contrôler son buzz ou alors là je dois
dire monsieur ardisson jeune je ne
comprends pas cette réponse mais mes
adhérents ont été très très très choquée
car en fait si la télé ne change pas la
vie sexuelle des gens alors à quoi
s'arrêter les coprésidents et le
courrier confirme cette impression des
millions de lettres les gens ont été
écoeuré dégoûté des gens qui ont jeté
leur téléviseur par la fenêtre des
suicides collectifs en bretagne tramway
de la jambe nous pas admis cette réponse
et bresse elle est contraire à téter
très choquant la terrre port de
différence dans ce pays il valérie
vraiment là le comprends pas en faisant
le choix de l'honnêteté valérie à briser
vos rêves et anéantit vos fantasmes et
vous l'avez donc condamnés dommage
valérie à bientôt peut-être oui tiré
d'ailleurs il faut bien dire aux
téléspectateurs que de la même façon si
quelque chose ne leur plaît pas dans les
missions qu'ils n'hésitent pas à nous le
signaler
nous sommes à votre service dites nous
ce qui ne va pas nous corrigerons
seconde nécessaire vous l'avez démontré
avec l'éviction de valérie cette
émission est avant tout la vôtre seuls
vos choix sont pris en compte d'ailleurs
à partir de maintenant en composant le
numéro habituel qui s'inscrit en bas de
votre écran
c'est vous qui décidez du programme
david weare il vous dit à partir de
maintenant mais ça a toujours été le cas
aujourd'hui nous renforçons encore grâce
à un dispositif informatique très
puissant nous renforçons encore ce
dispositif d'interactivité pour
permettre aux français de décider
hélas hélas je voudrais le dire vous
êtes dans la bonne voie 1 c'est la
parole aux téléspectateurs et j'en
profite du reste puisque j'ai deux
petites minutes peut être pour rappeler
les revendications principales de
l'association nationale téléspectateurs
français à savoir le ratio des
speakerines le respect des horaires et
surtout la présence d'un présentateur de
garder mais voilà la vae dit je le
répète pour sa part bien entendu
professeur si on passait au sujet oui eh
bien c'est ça thierry en parlant
d'interactivité la allons proposer une
choix de séquences aux téléspectateurs à
eux de décider en téléphonant au numéro
que vous avez indiquée
quelle séquence ils veulent voir le
choix leur est donné entre une chanson
inédite de claude françois a séquencé
magnifique réellement royal top une
séquence censure et de body le dernier
film de madonna qui envoie le bois
bouddhique soit le bois est bien plus
que le bois les images d'une exécution
capitale en arabie saoudite
particulièrement croustillante vous
l'imaginez pourrait elle vend ou bien
c'est le quatrième choix un extrait de
symphorien la série québécoise qui
passent la nuit sur tf1 pour remplir les
quotas
deux oeuvres francophones alors voilà le
choix qui est proposé à nos amis
téléspectateurs ils sont en train de
téléphoner massivement je regarde sur
mon écran de contrôle
l'opération se passe en temps réel non
nous
comme à 200 mille appels hambourg on les
appelle continue d'appuyer que vont
choisir nos amis que vont ils choisir
madonna claude françois non et bien
thierry ça s'est joué à pas grand-chose
nos amis ont choisi saint fort quel
bonheur s'étonnera je suis ravi en même
temps c'est étonnant car on est jeune
c'est bien la preuve que les gens de la
télé connaissent très mal leurs
téléspectateurs car moi pourtant suite
près de mes adhérents qui la connaît
bien
et ben j'aurais dit madonna tout de
suite oui ou peu françois ou claude
françois
quand même ya cinq ans quand on pense
qu'ils passent la nuit oui alors qu'il
pourrait faire un audimat extorqué en
passant ça amateurs de les gens le
demandent les jeunes veulent je suis
regardé les graffitis c'est voici
symphorien mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
la balle de nouvelle europe a cédé
groupe bcc spirituel visage horrifié
42,3 avec elton john st john le chanteur
tom jones est tombé dans l'eau et nous
avec un gorille à la volée c'est d'un
autre chanteuse qui n'est en tout cas
pas mal est aussi plus tenable à la dans
les hangars regarde d'en regarder oslo
we will you marry un guide à l'attention
alors professeur ça leur plaît
l'interactivité 1
mais c'est ce que les gens veulent tirer
la façon aux invités maintenant
professeur oui on a le choix entre quoi
et bien pour ce qui concerne les invités
nous leur proposons le choix entre
jeanne moreau qui est royal top
michèle morgan qui envoie le bois un
vrai concert président mais elle envoie
le bois
marie pierre cazé qui est royal top et
anouk aimée qui envoie le bois voilà
vous avez à choisir entre ses quatre
invités
quel beau soit vous l'avez dit il alors
c'est bien thierry je laisse encore un
peu de temps aux téléspectateurs pour
voter grâce au numéro habituel on voit
des centaines des milliers d'appels
entrer dans nos machines à ça se joue
dans un mouchoir de poche
bah voilà voilà la décision est tombée
les téléspectateurs ont choisi marié
recalde boehner
marie pierre cazé bonsoir bonsoir donc
vous jouez en ce moment sexe et jalousie
de marc camoletti oui au théâtre michel
avec jean luc moreau oui baudillon
patrick guillemin et le noir y agathe
boisseau on n'oublie personne
on n'oublie personne peut citer tous les
cas mal ça se fait oui c'est royal top
c'est royal st royal c'est quoi
l'histoire de la pièce a bien c'est un
mari trompé qui fait venir l'amant de sa
femme chez lui et qui lui dit carrément
outre youtube où je couche avec votre
femme
un gars comme ça vous allez souffrir
autant que moi et l'amant plein de
courage lui offre sa femme voilà ils
doivent se réunir au cours d'un dîner
que je vais orchestrée mais je ne vous
dirai pas la suite
carrier à suspense cette ip est très
drôle et je pense que le public
comprendra tout de suite dès qu'il aura
vu la pièce mais je ne dirai rien à voir
donc pour savoir la fin il faut qu'on
aille voir la pièce voilà c'est un peu
emmerdant quand même des débuts en plein
air y à l'entracte il faut rester voilà
après l'entracte
oui exactement à palau l'ont quand même
somme mais non c'est très court avant
questrecques ou très drôle très drôle
bon ça membres il faut drôle que vous
gagnez oui bah vous et moi j'avais chez
ford et ses soins y parvenir ou pour
être drôle
oui apparemment ça marche avec journée
ils marchent déjà marché les gens me
trouvent très très drôle ce soit royal
temps c'est royal tort alors voilà
la parole
il
alors c'est quoi dans sa vie c'est la
bonne vous avez vu je suis venu en
costume sensation en étant là pour faire
très attention hein c'est fait beaucoup
de théâtre s'est fait beaucoup de
théâtre beaucoup de cinéma les choses de
la vie l'été meurtrier de la télé oui
mais justement alors là je suis en
manque de télévision alors je pensais
être la potiche ça peu déçu parce
qu'elle a déjà dit ça y est c'est fait
c'est fait les tirs sont initiés c'était
fini c'est dommage à mon avis c'est le
lardy mathorez monte enfin avoir de quoi
y'a un truc qui vous énervez aussi
durablement j'aimerais en parler bah oui
parce que je sais que ça vous énerve
c'est sa beauté sa vie qu intervient le
nez rouge ouais c'est please oui et
pourquoi salon et on s'est d'abord
pourquoi ma please
pourquoi ça vous énerve s'améliore parce
que d'abord je déteste le ménage soutien
rien de plus ridicule que de faire le
ménage la poussière qui revient sans
cesse on sait pas tellement pencher sur
cette histoire
c'est un mystérieux cette poussière qui
vient on la chasse elle revient quand
elle est sur vous sur votre nez sur vos
yeux alors donc c'est une chose qui m'a
bien énormément et cette publicité s'est
fait comme ça par hasard et me collent à
la peau souvent oui alors je prends un
chiffon j'essaye de nettoyer tout ça il
voit qu'avec vous savez moi je fais
exprès vous n'avez pas ce que j'ai vu
dans tous les papiers ça vous que ça
vous énervez s'est insurgé remettre une
couche weezy s'arrête dans ma musique
pas tellement une heure voire finalement
c'est important je me donne du mal oui
non je vous trouve plutôt sympa tout et
qu'on la regarde la pub l'isla oui enfin
si nous sommes encore plus vous énervez
oui ça a peut-être encore m'énerver mais
tant pis alors là on va la regarder
bien sûr pelisse fait merveille pour
ôter la poussière mais ce n'est pas tout
avec qu'ils la poussière n'est pas
simplement déplacé elle reste sur le
chiffon résultat les meubles reste
brillant plus longtemps c'est tant mieux
parce que je ferais pas ça tous les
jours
[Applaudissements]
donc pour vous marie pierre cazé c'est
pas le théâtre c'est pas le cinéma c'est
pas les dramatiques à la télé c est ce
qu on peut répondre rien fait un verrier
nouvelles sur votre temps dont marc rapp
please j'espère que non ouais
ou alors je vais me faire incinérer
ouais ya des gens comme ça on viendra me
dire oui et tu retourneras à la
poussière
c'est vrai que pour faire le ménage dans
votre tête vous vous dites ça à faire le
ménage dans vos tâches qui prouve que
c'est ancré chez vous c'est vrai que
pour faire le ménage dans votre tête
fait du sabre oui non si je suis gaucher
et vous voulez relever le défi je vous
jette mon gant à la figure hélas en
coulisses mais le carré et on verra fait
voir et revoir quand vous faites du
sable comment ça fait un mouvement de
sabari d'abord comme ça ouais ouais
c'est exactement comme dans please take
esquivé
et
heureusement j'avais pas du tout on n'a
pas besoin de ça bon bah merci marie
pierre alors encore une fois bravo donc
plissée au théâtre michel dans l'église
de marc camoletti voilà c'est ça qui est
bien la soirée jean luce morand et nous
y voilà tu sais que c'est de la jalousie
va bien merci marie pierre terzian
quant au sol
l'interactivité c'est aussi pour nous la
ferons pour les téléspectateurs qui
prendrait les missions en cours de route
il est peut-être nécessaire de rappeler
la raison pour laquelle vous êtes
affublé de ce nez rouge bains pour être
drôle
voilà ce que j'ai décidé d'être drôle je
pense que ça fera monter l'audimat si je
suis drôle est-ce que ça fait rire tirer
[Applaudissements]
brian topp en effet nous nous disions
donc convertir y je disais que
l'interactivité c'est aussi pour vous la
possibilité de choisir la tenue de nos
télés petit pour cela il vous suffit de
composer le numéro habituel qui
s'inscrit en bas de votre écran
voila voila noter les petits ceux qui
rentrent enfin leurs vêtements tous les
cas oui tiens c'est cela qui est
intéressant avec l'interactivité c'est
que cela fonctionne sur un principe
extrêmement simple il suffit d'appeler
le numéro habituel et de donner son avis
c'est bien que ce soit habituelle va
c'est comme ça on est habitués mais on
s'en souvient bien sûr ça c'est vraiment
cher président ce que vous voulez dire
c'est royal pop
alors voici donc les quatre tenues qui
sont proposées aux téléspectateurs
si vous choisissez l'une de ses tenues
l'été les potiches seront désormais
habillées de cette façon voici d'abord
la caméra vous la montre la tenue numéro
un c'est assez franchement déshabiller
du maillot bleu
en fait eu lieu je crois que ce serait
royal top away la caméra vous montre
maintenant la tenue numéro 2 qui est
assez franchement déshabiller également
on peut dire mon cher président que
cette tenue en bois vous pouvez
également décider que noter les potiches
seront habillés avec la tenue numéro 3
qui vous est présentée maintenant qui
est également assez franchement des amis
je vous demande de bien vouloir imaginer
l'annuel dans cet accoutrement ça envoi
ret bien le bois c'est pas difficile à
imaginer
du 6 mars vite quand même ce qu'on dit
ça envoi ret bien le bois sans voir et
bien moi on essaie ça a trompé non parce
que c'est une expression provincial
séduit la 4e tenu que la caméra du
présente cette petite robe noire qui est
un peu moins franchement déshabiller et
que nous appelons la tenue numéro 4
voilà et bien alors on fait ça reste les
appels arrivent ils influent thierry le
mot n'est pas trop fort centaines de
milliers et de milliers
téléphonez téléphoner alors laissons aux
gens encore un peu de temps pour choisir
tenue numéro un numéro deux numéros 3
numéros 4 une nouvelle fois la lutte est
très serrée à la voilà c'est bien
thierry je crois que maintenant le
résultat ne bougera plus et la tenue
numéro 4 qui a été choisi par nos amis
téléspectateurs je suis ravi
professeur est ce que nos hôtes et les
potiches peuvent revêtir tout de suite
cette tenue est bien puisque tel est le
souhait des téléspectateurs prenons cela
comme un ordre mon cher thierry bon eh
bien en attendant interlude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors toujours plus d'interactivité
l'armee téléspectateurs vous allez
maintenant pouvoir choisir votre voix de
thierry ardisson
mais oui thierry c'est bien ça
l'interactivité parce qu'il se pourrait
que votre voix naturelle ne plaisent pas
aux téléspectateurs et il n'y aura
aucune raison dans ces conditions de la
leur infliger si ça pouvait nous faire
gagner quelques points ça serait roya
france mais très contents non mais
naturellement c'est pourquoi nous allons
effectivement leur proposer un éventail
de voix nouveau quatre choix leur sont
offerts alors tendez bien vos oreilles
chers téléspectateurs voici la voie
numéro un
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue au studio bonaparte
ans hardy matt elle a une voix ma foi
très mélodieuses d'encelade hier qu'elle
envoie le bois voie numéro de thierry si
vous le voulez bien à la même année
monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au studio
bones a pas pour animal
oui ça change oui lucho souhaite
modifier ce n'est pas à moi de le
prononcer non plus les sont nos amis
voté moins de voix numéro 3 mesdames et
monsieur bonsoir bienvenue tudieu peau
d'un père pour qui m chaque fois c'est
complètement différent oui c'est un
autre monde
enfin voici le dernier choix la voie
numéro 4
malama nausées monsieur bonsoir
bienvenue au studio à l'appart pour
artix mat
voilà il vient nos années télé
spectateurs ont commencé de voter une
nouvelle fois ce sont des centaines de
milliers d'appels qui arrive en temps
réel à notre standard je regarde les
courbes se dessiner l'ouvragé les
anxieux les diagrammes en bâton reste
voilà qu'il faut amuser à changements qu
areva
bah oui c'est m'avoir ivy millions
d'appels à la la c'est bien écouter
thierry plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
vous c'est la voix de thierry ardisson
mais
je viens
mais ça
aucun plaisir thierry voyait finalement
l'interactivité on s'en fait tout un
monde mais ça n'est pas si contraignant
que ça il suffit de laisser la parole
aux téléspectateurs ils ont ils ont un
grand bon sens et la héroïne le prouve
c'est tombé ça m'arrange bien là ce
coup-là d'envoi le bois ça aurait été
gênant si j'avais été obligé d'avoir la
voix d'un autre pendant toutes les
émissions alors que là c'est vraiment
royal top absolument professeurs je
crois qu'on va aller plus loin sur ce
truc d'interactivité là au moins on va
passer au top de l'interactivité
maintenance et vous téléspectateurs
qu'elle est choisir ma sortie rivière
kwaï
parmi les quatre propositions qui va
vous faire le professeur rollin où il
atterrit la fameuse sortie rivière quoi
et qui enchante toujours petits et
grands alors nous proposons aujourd'hui
à nos amis quatre destinations le choix
qu'ils feront sera respectée cela va
sans dire
comme toujours par notre animateur
inscrire dix ans nous proposons une
rencontre débat avec la troupe de terre
morte au théâtre national de la colline
c'est le choix numéro un intéressant
une projection débat spécial kurosawa à
la salle art et essai de bondy c'est le
choix numéro 2 une exposition sur le
thème le peintre et sa lumière est la
mjc de malakoff
c'est le choix numéro 3 et les coulisses
du spectacle de django edwards au
gymnase c'est le choix numéro 4 aïe
à vous de dire difficile un mois
j'aurais à choisir eh bien écoutez les
téléspectateurs ont commencé de voter
une nouvelle fois ça va se jouer
probablement à très peu de choses en
temps réel toujours des centaines de
milliers d'appels et bien je crois que
c'est le théâtre de la colline non non
non non non ça c'est charmant
rémis in extremis c'est le spectacle de
jango edwards keira le maire sortant
les parents professeurs vous savez au
mais je sais thierry rien ne vous ferez
alors vous avez le courage des héros du
film la rivière kwaï absolem ou
retournent
est ce que nos amis téléspectateurs
souhaite que le président laurent vient
avec nous ça en tout cas sans moyens une
seule question c'est que mes adhérents
le veulent ils adorent quand je sors
avec vous écoutez je ne sais pas si les
téléspectateurs le souhaite il faut le
leur demander alors allez-y votez votez
invités l'imitateur souhaitez vous que
le président lorrain y en avait au
numéro habituel appeler au numéro
habituel vous fait patienter un petit
peu forcément les moyens que les gens
aient le temps de se rendre à leur
téléphone pour nous donner leur verdict
qui a far est maintenant sur mon écran
et qui est oui les gens souhaitent que
vous en mets très heureux dans ses
services en
marco tu viens marre quand tu viens
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
et
ah ah
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
non
e
[Musique]
notre guide aux gets cosette special
d'efforts you aubry cole qu hier et ce
mystère de shakespeare
romero
non mais jamais
[Applaudissements]
oui
six pêcheurs tous ces noms les plus
[Applaudissements]
originales aubry jeudi à quimper risque
de faire la police est arrivée vers la
paix
au royaume des douanes en moi et dans
l'agglo des chats valero et oui c'est le
dernier mot non match à auch nord à
l'esprit ce dernier maurice grimaud
moscow world we mascotte des studios par
ailleurs mais l'affichage du kaiser
comme à moi que tu souhaites tu dois te
lever la bombe un mois que ce choix
comme en plein jour béni oui oui bon
dernier et wazup les gens mais les
joueurs arrivent les jeux via sa radio
ckoi the pleasure mois houeillès good
good guys ailleurs les poissons ou les
trois à la fois ce goût de momas guys
and fall ici les plus gentilles malaysie
times et britannique
olalala au mercy président vous êtes
venu comme ça moi déjà d'une aide totale
président wade belak noches mis à mort
les héros du show sympathique et le tout
[Musique]
sympathique ce garçon est allé j'ai
simplement peur d'une petite 206 et que
nous a quand même légèrement que je
n'essaie pas grave vous allez voir le
temps d'arriver au studio on sera propre
ah oui assez c'est l'été les spurs mais
non n'ayez pas peur n'ayez pas peur
allez vous allez voir le temps d'arriver
aux stups lui on se rapproche c'est tout
la paix mais c'est ça la télé vous allez
voir vous allez tout propre vous allez
voir tous coiffés cas les faits
je fais
bien c'est fait
à
[Musique]
antijaponaises ça va alors professeur
sans voile voix non oui je dirais même
thierry que c'est royal top et le fait
que vous marchiez comme un clown en
entrant dans ce studio ne gâte rien
et c'est qu'ils savaient professeur
quand on fait ce que les gens veulent
ils aiment mais oui à tel point qu'il y
a un léger risque pour nous maintenant
de dépasser notre quota de parts de
marché je me demande s'il ne serait pas
nécessaire pour faire baisser l'audience
de mettre un petit coup de jacques
martin et si ça ne suffisait pas
peut-être un petit morceau de laurent
ruquier encore que j'espère qu'il sera
pas nécessaire d'en arriver là ça va
marcher
l'audience va baisser et professeur à la
tienne mon petit facteur avoir goûté ça
mon pote tu vas voir on y ait du sens
lumière je pense que c'est bon dis donc
tu penses à venir chercher d'humour
d'acteurs aux lions ça marche machemont
fort a pour l'elysée il paraît qu'ils
ont fait 48 % 48 % dans les sondages
nord dans les écoutes
dites donc
sur tf1 les reality cendres de plus en
plus loin c'est vraiment plus en plus
loin que les horaires prévus
on se couche à trois heures du matin là
pour savoir qui a sauté la petite fille
allez vas-y vas-y tu seras une mode pour
cabo des femmes fatiguées a demandé à
être mis sur écoute
arte a demandé à était sur écoute mais
pourquoi dieu pour avoir des gens il
paraît que guillaume du rhin est devenu
écologiste
ah bon mais comment il est fait il a
regardé l'audience de ces émissions
et ça l'a rendu vers c'est de la
dynamite ce truc là très efficace
l'audience a plongé comme un plongeur a
et ça ça marche à tous les coups sûrs un
problème cesap aventis à poney c'est qui
veut pas mourir dans sa tournée 1 1 1 1
1 1
il veut rester en vie nos abonnés oui
oui oui les chaînons ça c'est bizarre
oui tu as as alsace ne vous aurait pas
lécher saint-palais cher à nous la
napoule nana là qu'on peut pour
l'audience professeur oui oui mon dieu
mon dieu je regarde mon ordinateur
n'étant pas là la jeune lucie bisson
laisse trop il va falloir que vous le
cul y est
oh lola lola
le château c'est moi c'est quoi
ah non non non j'en peux plus je t'aime
ivica derrière pour toi dans cette
émission pour l'heure m en leur nom
philippe allez vas t'en vas tu fais peur
je t'ai dit que rien pour toi dans cette
émission écoute des charges je le sais
quoi je ne peux plus de l'evel suffisant
jusqu'à 20 kg fait d'effort 1 ou le nom
bon je m'en vais la zone d'attenté pour
témoin encore type à se marier
c'est embêtant monsieur corti n'ai pas
aimées du public et il a encore fait
plonger l'audience jusque dans des
profondeurs un petit peu inquiétant
heureusement j'ai ce qu'il faut aux
professeurs à l'humanitaire ça marche
toujours l'humanitaire alors c'est une
bonne idée ça ne marche pas toujours
mais en ce moment en tout cas ça marche
il a alors j'en mi-2012 haine ou la rage
et pas lésiné s'appelle troyat le top ça
va vous allez voir ça va envoyer le bois
abbès envoie le bois terriblement vous
allez voir regarder
[Musique]
m
on me dira ce
[Musique]
quand tu viens des besoins
et
[Musique]
dany
vaud
tout va
oui
[Musique]
on
le sou
[Musique]
et
ah ah
dunod
besoin oui
oui
[Musique]
il
arrêtez moi ça arrêtez moi l'humanitaire
tout de suite on est en train de
décoller mon ordinateur fume on ne va
pas tarder à toucher le plafond
je croyais bien faire moi ben oui mais
thierry trop c'est trop a comme dit le
proverbe mais monsieur ardisson pendant
que nous sommes au top de l'audience est
ce que vous ne pourriez pas faire venir
au g11 hakoum aviez promis parce que
comme ça il va être accueilli par une
foule incroyable ça faisait jamais
premier rose et lancé ainsi si une jeune
maison la semaine dernière au téléphone
mais vous ai appelé m'avait promis
projet n'en a jamais me sur 10 sont
jamais enfin jamais je n'ai jamais
promis roger lanzac
monsieur le président si thierry vous
dit qu'il ne l'a jamais promis c'est
probablement qu'il ne l'a jamais promis
oui je n'ose pas croire que monsieur
ardisson comme tous les gens de la télé
mans comme monsieur mougeotte avec le
retour de patrick sabatier mais bon je
ne suis pas loin de le croire tant a
ajouté j'ai beaucoup mieux projets dans
un ghetto soit son président à un
quelqu'un qui fait autant d'audience
aujourd'hui que roger lanzac qu'on
faisait à l'époque qui dont hélène
hélène avec les garçons n'ont et lan
sans les garçons ah oui bon d'accord
mais ça risque de faire ton monte avec
les garçons alors c'est bien voici
élèves
[Musique]
donc tu es l'héroïne de hélène et les
garçons sur tf1 après avoir été actrice
dans premiers baisers
est ce que tu peux nous raconter comment
c'est arrivé ce rêve comment tu vas
rencontrer ton producteur jean luc
azoulay
je les ai rencontrés au mans n'avance
occupé des spectacles sur le mans voilà
on l'a rencontré comme ça elle a fait
dorothée voilà l organiser des
spectacles dorothée au mans et c'est
comme ça que tu l'a rencontré parce
qu'il est aussi le producteur il faut le
dire de dorothée oui oui je t'entends
comment avec de rethel très bien ça va
pas de jalousie entre vous vous êtes
dans la même maison de production et
prom gagne et qu'on fait ça parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'histoire quoi est-ce que
hélas est ce que comme dorothée toi tu
n'as pas dû non plus quand je n'aurai
rien mon garçon s'appelle rachel par
contre mais pour le moment c'est pareil
tout les ne faisait pas le temps d'avoir
des jules en fait
oh c'est pas que j'ai pas le temps c'est
bon et toujours pas mais j'ai pas envie
ouais c'est pas à cause du planning non
ça se passe comment une journée d'hélène
ça commence à 8h matin jusqu'à
normalement 20 heures mais ça dépasse
toujours à pau et quand tu rentres chez
toi tu as des textes à apprendre pour le
tu tournes combien d'heures par jour on
10 12h à peu près le lundi mardi jeudi
vendredi un bond et le week-end qu'est
ce que tu fais tu restes à paris où j'ai
pas en campagne tueur retourne vers tes
parents tout le week-end tous les
week-ends oui j'aimerais l'accompagner
moi tu te souviens de belle et sébastien
oui je me souviens bien c'est de belle
et sébastien parce que quand j'étais
petit
ocp la maîtresse venait me chercher pour
calmer la place et on chantait avec ma
soeur me souviens quand tu chantais des
chansons de stone et charden
oui je me souviens je faisais stone et
ma soeur comme elle est brune à feu des
sharks mais tu sais que le président
adore ça ne l'est pas nous en faire un
petit bout tous les deux
je suis au comble du bonheur mais hier
je sais c'est pour vous par exemple
mehdi normandie par exemple par exemple
allez au hasard
les taches rouges blanches et noires sur
lesquels tombent eux l'appui et les
cerisiers blanc mehdi normanville
au moment où télévision toute une
jeunesse grand moment de télévision
hélène est ce que tu as peur de l'amour
non ça sert à rien est-ce que tu as peur
de grossir
t'as plus peur de grossir que de la mort
dis moi hélène tu fais un feuilleton qui
fait 40% de parts de marché sur tf1 tu
veux pas qu'on en fasse un petit bout là
pour faire un peu remonter l'audience
mardi matin à manger des potiches -
stéphanie tu y vas tu t'y coll oui vous
en pensez quoi
on fait ça on s'est pas de refus thierry
parce que un vous avez parlé de la mort
fait toujours baisser l'audience
et puis 2 ce qui est encore plus grave
le président a chanté et le retrait le
président chante oui mais l'ancien
président votre chanson n'a pas été très
appréciée avait dépêché news vous êtes
en place
très bien alors emmanuel si tu veux bien
commencé salut tu viens pour le casting
toi aussi
bah oui vous nous aussi on annule
annonçant une interview tu sais le canal
de dechavanne
mais non c'est pas de chaval ces petits
riens ardisson l'embellissent et la ccoo
faut toujours ces deux là ah bon
pourtant thierry ardisson est quand même
beaucoup de choses ça beau tu trouves
moi j'aime bien les challenges les
belles cravates
ah oui c'est vrai mais c'est quand même
important il ya deux choses que je
regarde c'est un garçon sérieux et ça
travaille ne remarque pourquoi pas vous
regarder je crois que c'est lui qui sort
de chavaignes mignon thierry ardisson
attendait surtout nous sommes nuls à ch
ça lui fait tout et thierry ardisson oui
c'est moi vous venez pour la danse
oui c'est ça c'est pourquoi c'est pour
le juste prix
non c'est pour une nouvelle sitcom que
nous préparons sur france 2 thierry et
les filles aux d'un joli titre à sa
merci c'est moi qui l'ait trouvée alors
qu'est ce que vous avez fait jusqu'à
maintenant
moi j'étais petit johnny supermarchés et
moi dans les discothèques et toi moi
j'ai fait beaucoup poterie poterie
potiche c'est pas loin alors dites moi
quel est votre rêve moi c'est d'être une
vedette vide et n importe quoi mais une
faute est oui et toi et moi c'est d'être
une star une grande stars comme madonna
christine ockrent
oui c'est vrai que c'est pas mal de
choses et toi c'est quoi ton rêve moi ce
serait de faire le printemps de bourges
à bas les filles je suis désolé c'est
elle qui est engagée parce que sur cette
chaîne
quand on parle de bourges on a gagné d
avance
[Applaudissements]
content très content attention ça fait
mais je suis sûr et là c'est bien
alors comme il est maintenant tradition
comme le dirait professeur rollin je
vais faire un petit cadeau à hélène
comme à tous les invités importants du
monde de la télé qui viennent alors elle
est j'ai deux petits cadeaux à vous
faire d'abord ce petit cristal de roche
car je sais que votre père dans les
vielles pierres et que vous êtes comme
votre père vous aimait les vielles
pierres
mais cette pire là est un peu symbolique
car je voudrais que et mes adhérents
voudrait que comme cette pierre votre
carré votre carrière brille est dur très
long voilà c'est petit et lui
je vous ai préparé non maintenant j'ai
un petit buzz qui ne sait pas s'il me
souviens toutes les paroles un petit pot
pourri des jeunes car vous savez qu'il
ya trois chansons sur hélène alors seul
sur le sable les pieds dans l'eau mon
rêve était trop beau l'été qui s'achève
tu partiras dans ton pays loin là bas
hélène si je t'écris aux kerguelen
c'est parce qu'ici sans le savoir si à
laisser quelqu'un qui tirait élèves et
les techniques suis pas vers les piétons
mais je t'écris quand même que je t'aime
et les olalala voilà c'est bien si vite
fait bien fait comme on dit à montluçon
très bien et bien hélène merci c'était
vraiment royal top on peut dire que tu
envoies le bois à bientôt
mais
[Applaudissements]
sans voile loi c-10 yalta plaisir à la
voir elle est allée elle et elle est
jeune elle est jolie et vous savez j'ai
remarqué une chose c'est que mes
adhérents adore les légendes jeunes un
très très jeune à la télé ils adorent ça
il en réclame énormément vous avez pas
ça bien sûr j'ai tout ce qu'il vous faut
voici le petit elvis
m
or
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
souvent
le sol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
réussit pas mal me voyez pas la même
chose en plus plus en plus jeunes oui
pas de problème
[Musique]
bon son
m
[Musique]
c'est pas mal il ne voyait pas la même
chose en plus en plus jeunes oui pas de
problème
[Musique]
et
c'est pas mal me voyez pas la même chose
en plus en plus jeunes oui pas de
problème
[Musique]
c'est pas mal mais je voyais pas la même
chose en plus en plus jeunes oui pas de
problème c'est pas mal me voyez pas la
même chose en plus en plus jeunes oui
pas de problème
[Musique]
ça fait un moment que je vous voyais
venir avec vos gros sabots
la diffusion de cette séquence
pornographiques constitue une infraction
d'une extrême gravité
je suis obligé de sanctionner par 43
secondes de venise documentaires
culturels à venise après cet intermède
aussi fleuri qu parfumer les palets
reprennent leurs fiers démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un frémissement
que seul claude monet son chevalet
l'audience à la peine terrible un nom en
effet ce n'est pas à proprement parler
terrible enfin ne vous plaignez pas
c'est de votre faute vous qui avait
diffusé des cochonneries moi c'est je
n'ai fait que mon devoir j'ai un truc
pas mal remarquer truc vraiment sympa qu
envoie le bois très royale top 10 est le
monde celle hariri voici le comique
indien
[Musique]
mme lagarde
ces appareils nous faire marrer du tout
vous bah écoutez je ne sais pas monsieur
dix ans c'était peut-être pas mon genre
de comics trucs qui m'ont échappé pas
vraiment poil et comment on dit non mais
vous allez avoir un petit bout là
peut-être mis en tête d'aller voir au
touquet par guy et je n'imaginais aux
mobiles apple
jamais à william henzell rossano
m
sophie bonsoir bienvenue dans bienvenue
dans leurs dix matches se fit je vois
que tu es venu avec ton agent il prend
combien il prend 10% 15% 20% 25%
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya mais c'était un
gag c'est un gag
je sais pas ce que j'ai ligne il avoue
par à manger fille tu me magatte la
mauvaise ambiance et c'est peut-être
comment on pouvait parler d'argent
qu'ils savaient pas en danger c'est un
petit peu et thierry puisque nous étions
dans les cochonneries reste on dit je
voulais vous signaler que il y à une
émission qui nous a fait beaucoup de mal
samedi dernier et qui nous a battus
c'était le documentaire consacré à lady
di sur m6 alors est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de vous laisser damer le
pion comme ça chaque semaine non enfin
j'ai un truc on va regarder c'est le
mariage de monsieur madame berthier à la
roche-posay ah oui bien sûr oui on
regarde
[Musique]
oh
vous n'auriez pas la même chose en plus
piquant plus piquant
[Musique]
vous
oui ça c'est bien c'est bien mais en
même temps que celles dans les mailles à
ce qui marche bien c'est la robe de
mariée
avec avec robe de mariée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors un oui oui ça c'est bien c'est de
mieux en mieux c'est bien cher président
vous dites c'est bien vous voulez dire
seroyal top pardon voilà bien le bout ce
qui serait bien c'est la même chose avec
deux robes de mariée ça vous avez ça
avec des robes de mariée
[Musique]
non
paris
je pense aux aéroports
mais
[Musique]
nous étions l'autre
cinquième invité le directeur du figaro
basile de coke
[Applaudissements]
président de club bonsoir je suis à dix
ans bienvenue sur le plateau d'art
d'image série diffusée mois il faut
peut-être prévenir votre invité de la
raison pour laquelle vous portez ce nez
rouge des bilans oui c'est vrai parce
que j'ai décidé d'être drôle
on m'a expliqué que tous mes collègues
était drôle à la télévision que moi
c'était un petit peu tangents alors
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
pour la paix la voilà oui j'ai une
tension amusant désormais je suis drôle
alors basile de coqs donc vous éditez le
figaro mais tu as un quotidien je pense
et c'est il est à combien d'exemplaires
le figaro deux cent mille exemplaires 20
francs en vente partout dans tous les
kiosques de notre chère et vieille
france y compris les colonies mais pas
qu'il ya eu un pastiche qui a été fait
du figaro déjà dans bien sûr il s'agit
d'un coup bas qui vient de haut
il ya une caricature grossière du figaro
qui circulent actuellement dans les
kiosques et qui tourne en dérision nos
positions courageuses
alors nous avons enquêté la sphère est
simple ne véritable manipulateur de se
tasser est un ancien du nouvel obs
lui-même et d'autre part nous avons la
preuve de la préméditation s'appelle
commence ce pastiche du figaro le titre
de jean coutu un titre absurde savez le
figaro ils vont chercher
nous avons la preuve de la préméditation
puisque ce pastiche circulent et
circulait déjà avant la sortie de notre
qu'auditif à notre quotidien mais il ya
des programmes télé dans le figaro oui
malheureusement il ya des programmes
télé
qui montre suffisamment que la
télévision est devenue un des
instruments principaux du pourrissement
notre beau pays je quelques exemples il
y en aurait trop à citer malheureusement
vous avez ces séries de dessins animés
nippons pornographiques comme skeletor
contre pin enfer où je ne sais quoi
les feuilletons américains débile je
pense à papa shufu téléshopping et puis
tous ces jeux plus bête les uns que les
autres comme par exemple un deux trois
soleil dont on ne comprend même pas la
règle mais je dois dire monsieur hardy
matt que vous donnez chapet pas à la
critique que nous faisons ici au figaro
d'un autre journal car vous participez
de cette entreprise de pourrissement
vous êtes même un peu la caricature
écoutez votre émission
qu'est ce que c'est c'est le débraillé
au physique et au moral
vous devez quand même un minimum de
respect aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
payent la redevance n'est ce pas et vous
présenter cette émission en maillot de
corps pourriez au moins avoir une
cravate et chemise comme tout le monde
votre émission c'est aussi la violence
ou menaces et un chien puissant et
malheureuse et les gens regardent votre
mission c'est le sexe il ya à peine un
mois vous avez diffusé en direct une
fellation qui en plus n'a même pas
réussi
j'ai pas la peine de neil je vais
enregistrer je la regarde tous les soirs
et au delà de ça il ya pire
je pense qu'il y a des messages
subliminaux qui vous fait passer à
travers votre émission des amis à moi
m'ont déjà expliqué comment vous faisiez
la 25e images dans laquelle vous faites
passer des diaporamas avec des jeunes
qui se piquent à l'herbe
vous croyez que c'est du beau travail ça
et il n'y a pas que ça j'ai l'impression
mais je n'en suis pas sûr je ne
l'affirmé pas j'ai l'impression que dans
votre émission
quand on écoute le générique à l'envers
on entend distinctement une voix qui
susurre sodome à moins que ce soit
saddam
de toute façon vraiment vous participez
de cette entreprise je suis désolé de
vous le dire parce que j'ai pas l'air de
renvoyer l'ascenseur
enfin dans le copinage artistique de la
classe médiatique mais je me dois de
dire la vérité au nom de tous nos
lecteurs et de tous les vrais français
alors évidemment il faudra supprimer
votre émission puisque vous êtes amateur
de scoop j'en ai un ces votes rason
dernière émission ce soir
mais où est raccompagné monsieur s'il
vous plaît commence à me raccompagne il
n'y avait pas d'autres questions non
mais c'est scandaleux
le figaro est en vente dans tous les
kiosques vraiment france est vraiment
libre
demandez le figaro
eh bien ma foi rôle à une émission qui
me paraît avoir bien envoyé le bois je
dirais que dans l'ensemble l'été royal
top je consulte et médias g en camembert
il manque peut-être une petite chose
nous avons tous les ingrédients
il manque peut-être tout de même un
petit peu de violence n'ont pas eu assez
si vous aviez quelque chose avec du sang
frais les tripes train j'ai une femme
violente
ça va ça c'est pas mal ça nous mettra un
petit peu trop de femmes mais on
enlèvera
oh
[Musique]
boum
baby baby baby baby baby
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
ok non wayne et de gouttes farc
c'est peut-être royal top monsieur
ardisson mais je suis désolé encore de
la violence toujours de la violence des
100 marches mais pensez peut-être mais
je suis désolé mais adhérents n'aime pas
beaucoup la violent et la défense a
marre peut-être mais adhérents il aime
la belle télé là oui mais ça marche ça
marche ça marche les adhérents ce qu'ils
aiment c'est les émissions pour enfants
qui marchent aussi bien que l'avion je
suis désolé rabat à la même heure avec
me rappelez vous me sur 10 sont trente
30 ma jument va le tua d elles courent
courent eux dans le vent et la vie est
belle
12h02 villembits porter la joie de vivre
nous les petits et les grands pourront
ils vont le suivre
gopher des quatre rigole l'éclipsé fait
sourire
voilà lé des cirques qui rigolait la
houlette voilà qui fuyaient la quille et
déjà sûre bien sûr j'étais désolé mais
sur six ans a fait autant d'audience que
la violence sont les tubes we un tube à
propos de tubes monsieur ardisson il y à
une dame que j'ai adoré que les
téléspectateurs ont adoré que mes
adhérents plébiscité une charmante jeune
femme qui a été un royal top tube de la
présentation télé je pense à gillett
il ya des semaines que vous me promettez
ses nouvelles je crois me sur 10 sont en
fait que vous n'êtes pas le magicien de
la télé que vante le professeur rollin
vous travaillez vraiment pour l'argent
vers des choses thierry ne voulait
jamais promis mais jamais jamais mais
sur un essai de la joie je ne crois pas
il y a un père passe pour l'instant si
vous le voulez vous laissez votre
sentiment après le bip sonore avec un
camp
gillet de bonsoir c'est thierry ardisson
le présentateur d' hardy matt est ce que
tu es cacher derrière ton répondeur
sommes en direct et voulu préciser
gillett
écoute je ne sais pas si longtemps ce
message en tous les cas lorsque tu
l'entendra rappelle moi parce que le
président lorrain qui représente 18
millions d'adhérents et désireux de te
recevoir sur ce plateau et je suis sûr
que tu serais très heureuse de découvrir
le petit cadeau qu'il a préparé pour toi
voilà gillett
thierry ardisson 47 42 13 50
j'attends un appel à bientôt à bientôt
tout jamais au dôme à damas ou qu'est-ce
que je peux faire de plus
non je vois que vous travaillez c'est
raide c'est vrai c'est vrai j'étais pour
la peine celle des messages tous les
jours elle répond pas je ne sais pas
peut-être est-elle dégoûté de la télé je
ne sais pas si elle ne répond pas
qu'est-ce que j'y peux moi de vous
mettez pas en colère mais vous
m'emmerdez la fin août et je crois qu'on
peut tout dire de moi sauf que je fais
pas mon boulot hein
non monsieur a dit son nom mais moi non
d'accord mais on est quand même habitué
aux mensonges des gens de télé donc
c'est pour ça je me permettait de mettre
en doute votre travail vous le faites
c'est très bien bravo monsieur rocher
appelé j'ai laissé un message vous avez
vu si elle ne veut pas répondre tant pis
pour elle pas de retour à la télé
désunion personnes qui ne font pas
l'avoir d'accord mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs hardy matt s'achève à bien le
lot
excusez moi
là vous êtes en train de dénoncer la fin
de l'émission bah oui et en même temps
vous aviez annoncé notre ami didier
gustin dans le sommaire on ne l'a pas eu
vous êtes marrant vous aussi écouter
didier gustin on l'attend depuis chez
parmi les missions qu'on l'attend il
avait qu'à venir marquer c'est bon ben
je voulais s'annonce moi je suis désolé
on plie les gaules martin bonnet rouge
super gt si d'état feront louis à
[Applaudissements]
pendant sa nou ce cas cela ça fait une
plante monde attend ah non c'était hyper
dur à venir après je me suis garé sur
les coupes dans une gare en de la paille
mais non non on y arrive après non non
moi je suis désolé monsieur ardisson en
mai contre il s'en fout j'avais une
super chanson de didier on vous laisse
les caméras on vous laisse le studio
fait votre peau
allez-y n'avait qu'à être là lors génial
et non non non je suis désolé moi dit il
avec ma tante a lui aussi salué didier
rous et toi combien d'émissions l'a fait
là j'en ai peur ça suffit le mec il
exagère énorme envers laquelle harry
vient je veux dire il ya un peu gonflé
gustin ouais moi je trouve qu'il a un
petit peu conclut madame dressez-vous
moi ça pue ici
c'est sentir toi ça pue ici façon le
petit fonctionnaire qui s'est glissé
pour aérer les toits aux brésiliennes sa
puce vous dit rien bon je vais faire moi
même l'une cardio oui je vois qu on
s'enlise alors un canton s'enlise je
suis là aujourd'hui je suis gai comme un
bel quand il sait qu'il aura de la bière
et des frites suivi faire cet été ne
vous inquiétez pas alors allez question
halak en question a redit con pour faire
cette émission gustave les couches et
avec qui avec christine bravo ou avec ar
10 ans mais avec tout le monde les deux
mon petit tout le monde
le chef opérateur la maquilleuse les
cadreurs le public tout le monde mon
petit tout le monde je vais te dire un
truc mon petit c'était bon en mettant le
compte de questions à la con comme ça ah
oui c'est ma spécialité j'en ai dit
comme ça nous en faire une petit
dites moi alors dites-moi quand vous
faites la mort aux fumées avant pendant
ou après non je fume jamais non non le
sillage préfère lui mais quand ils sont
bien frais j'arrive à percevoir la sueur
des belles cubaine qui les ont roulé sur
leurs cuisses
je me muscler narines vous comprenez
alors bon je mentionnais le président de
la république alors monsieur le
président de la république une petite
question vaut baisser dans les sondages
est ce que ça vous fait quelque chose oh
vous savez plus ce baisse dans les
sondages et plus je grimpe
comment est-il pas d'accord merci fixe
c'est le président en monsieur le
président une autre question vous ne
vous posez pas trop de questions ce
moment
aussi je me pose des questions
essentielles sur la vie pourquoi mais
pourquoi pourquoi ils dromadaires
ont-ils les couilles sur le dos ça c'est
les questions essentielles
bonsoir bonsoir et les fajitas que vous
entendez par là à hainan main avec
talent et la marque yachts et des sabres
22,2 soucy la menace des flammes si la
nature était juste il faut regarder du
fameux le têt qui ont atteint de pêche
et d'autres adultes du noyau d'accord
mais elle parlait vraiment mais il est
resté jusqu'à la fin votations sont nuls
elles sont aussi une occasion mais
peut-être tu arrêtes liminana histoire
hyper lourd laurent quelqu'un qui fait à
l'équipe au lycée non selon florent côté
que vous allez faire s'il faudrait lui
donner au niveau des téléphones de la
force en liberté intérieure des
partenaires at-elle répété hier matin
debian lenny moins dynamiques patenté
manette
[Musique]
madame a
m
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu